it's nice travel with the wife you know
Nina's message of the day is
let me ask you a question this is what
the chemical family doesn't a traffic
jam friends okay believe Asian we are
heading to the west coast and we're
going to take you on our journey with us
[Music]
so we just got back from Greece four
days ago
then we are traveling again why first
stop is BC and then I'm heading to LA BC
because my ex-wife recently moved out
there for a bunch of reasons but I don't
get to see Hayden as much so he comes
over the plan is on all the extended
breaks so extended break over Christmas
over summer March break but we've got a
long weekend coming up and so we're
gonna go surprise him over there and
spend the weekend with him Nina's gonna
come back and then I'm gonna go to head
to LA for vid summit where I'm doing a
presentation with Tim Schmoyer and their
leaves let's go
[Music]
don't give anything this way she gets
angry
[Music]
it's nice travel with the wife you know
that was a cute face you made Nina's
message of the day is
and join us at one of my boys on this
trip
like crazy check bouncing ain't healthy
eating
[Music]
try and try to stick to the diet as much
as possible will have a lot of special
treats if it's if you have to try like a
local special but just veg it out alike
but finally thing that's like a special
you have to try I'm going to try it but
not just junk out oh I'm sure that's the
goal we'll probably go I attempt this
delayed I'll even debate this -
hopefully we'll make some of the time up
on route though should be a mostly
smooth plate except for perhaps the
first hours so
[Music]
five hour flight done time to go get
Hayden and then drive for mr. Vancouver
oh oh that's cold
that is some called my friend whoo
welcome to Kelowna British Columbia so
like I said my ex-wife and Hayden and
her husband moved out to Kelowna for
various reasons that it's not my story
to share but it's been it's been tough
not being able to see Hayden as much
what we've done is every morning at 7:15
his time 10:15 my time we do a Google
hangout so I get to see him on camera I
had to make major adjustments that's
normally 10:15 I'm working not hanging
out but it's you know not easy but
that's life you make the best of it and
I'm super pumped that we can be here
that this line we can to see him so I'm
gonna get our car and make the drive I
have the key it's a silver BMW yeah do
you see a silver BMW somewhere where
there this yeah all right looks like
this is our ride for the next three days
it's a driving machine right isn't that
what BMW is driving machine because my
wife is a is a special machine there's a
special machine
[Music]
all right we have a ride hey whoo for
privacy reasons not gonna go and film
picking up Hayden but the next time you
see him or next time you see us well I
guess the next clip you're gonna see a
Hayden in the backseat so exciting
ha ha look who it is we got a little
Carmichael in the backseat my friends
what do you got to say for yourself
Hayden what do you want to tell believe
nation we tried to surprise him it was a
big surprise and then my mom called and
she didn't know it was a surprise and
shows she kind of ruined the surprise
but it's okay it's it's okay because
we're here we made it right now after
our five hours of dry a flight what are
we gonna do Nina we're gonna drive for
our drive to Vancouver Hayden's ever
been there Nina's never been there I've
been there so I have to be to a guide
ready set go go go
[Music]
we are sitting in a traffic jam and
Hayden has a special chill message don't
hit the hand that's filming ok this is
what the chemical family does in a
traffic jam friends traffic jams and
your best friends alright this goes get
to finally get their blueprints sit down
all day
[Music]
okay so a little bit of chaos and trying
to find our spot but you know what the
goats are coming home yeah Nina is an
expert navigator she's got the comical
orienteering Jean in her now that she
found our spot
so we'd landed we've got our parking
spot and now we're gonna go find our
Airbnb yeah let her figure out where
we're going first
this is Nina getting organized we love
you Nina
we love you all right now she's on us
she's determined look get the determined
face now we know what we're doing is
this what we're going this looks very
ghetto all right
the back entrance okay good here we go
don't go
[Music]
welcome to our happily ever after all
right here we are nice nice
what is this oh there you go that's the
bedroom look at that view huh that's
pretty awesome
no that's pretty cool what do you mean
we're right downtown that's awesome okay
so this is one bedroom let's see let's
pick the best bedroom for us and then
Hayden get whatever she wants okay
that's another door out okay okay okay
okay okay oh okay
and then this is better okay so I guess
that guess that was the master but there
by the door by the window okay hey then
you get to pick a room okay time to get
settled settled settled settled and then
explore Vancouver and eat power ever
[Music]
all right dropped off our stuff we're
gonna go for dinner in a hidden gem
restaurant here in Vancouver Nina always
loves special food local treats so part
of my job always is figuring out
something to make her happy
right wife right and then all right then
we'll gonna have to watch out for the
donkeys at Liz's
attack I mean the goats hey Nina look we
have right next to our place we got a
look at look straight ahead on the right
what no just only had today wasn't good
no hot chocolate Starbucks tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow we know where we're
coming to I'm still gonna find my Tim
Hortons oh yeah right now we gotta eat
dinner
straight straight straight
okay Nina we're here hidden gem no no no
I'll keep going big for a vape shop now
next the hidden gem in Vancouver Tokyo
Joe's well it's supposed to be very good
Japanese food so let's try it
starting with Hayden's favorite edamame
you got to go get edamame if you're
taking Tate into a Japanese place you're
gonna try one let's see
first impressions usually feel NEMA
doing first impressions but this one is
yours so moment of truth
which way that I'm going bomb is going
off nice salty
okay first role came out try it up Nina
where we got salmon on the outside
shrimp and asparagus on the inside
cameras star you near the camera star
let's go round one inna my mouth is
watering
[Music]
nice good alright next look at that Wow
that Oh God hooked up holy cow miso soup
and too hard to try too hard
all right I can either try the new role
here Henry and then this is a deep-fried
what's it called the normal dynamite
roll this is yours Hayden Peyton's gonna
try the deep-fried dynamite roll go far
[Music]
Wow best I not always ever tasted
wow he was skeptical he wasn't sure all
right it's a win all around good job
Evan way to pick a good restaurant for
these guys
I got a thank-you from Hayden but
nothing from Nina you know all right
wait a minute
did you hear her say it no I didn't
either all right all right dinners done
how we feeling how we feeling yeah what
are we gonna what are we gonna rank this
place good out of tang what are we
giving it a hundred
wha-ha-ha off the scale 88 88 attending
mediate anything okay let me ask you a
question do we want to have a specialty
dessert specialty artisan handcrafted Oh
very well-known famous specialty dessert
yeah or now or just like go home and
sleep no no no sir okay let's go
[Music]
Nina's gonna rush ahead and get her
jacket cuz it's a little cold here in
Vancouver how you doing good good but
you got your jacket on
alright go Nina we love you we'll see
you soon
wait what how this is working honey what
changing the rules are you doing okay so
you're gonna be a league of Legends
character and I have to guess who it is
that's the game okay go what the heck is
that I don't know he jumps he's on the
he's a frog who does that nobody
crunches on the floor like that no
keyboard does not do that okay okay
Green Goblin
[Music]
Nina got her sweater I feel like it's a
warm one you know why
look at that warm sweater look what's on
the back of that what kind of sweater is
that oh yeah that's definitely giving
some believed nation warmth and love to
Nina they need a look we got a Tim
Horton's across the street from us very
exciting Colts that you want some ice
cream I don't think so let's go let's go
we're getting our fancy dessert
specialty fancy dessert all right this
is it
fancy doughnuts guys fancy doughnuts get
in there
oh are they all out oh here oh there's
not a lot left but this some these fans
are doing it
that's true that's true are you sneaking
a bite are you sneaking the fight and is
it yummy could be yeah that's way from
Zig Vanina is she goes she's bringing
some bring some water okay Nina take a
bite just try
[Music]
[Music]
how's your his drinking it out all right
Danny okay time to get this guy home
and then bedtime that we can have an
amazing day tomorrow right
home home home
[Music]
everybody Taylor here one the streets of
Vancouver just running the Taylor born
and raised in Vancouver what's your
favorite video in the channel probably
the I think Gary Vee was like I think
that's what I found Garrity was three
years out all the years ago I loved it
man
yeah yeah and he just learned Petersons
- you didn't think okay he's Canadian
you know that I know it's a lot of drama
I just saw him debates I'm hair school
once ago just up here alright
yeah nice man takes you same hang for
sure man cheers Cheers
[Music]
all right well it's been a fun day one
it's been a lot of time on the plane a
lot of time in a car but amazing to get
to spend time with Hayden again and just
a really fun afternoon evening I'm
excited for this chip just got back from
a crazy trip and they have to go to LA
after this and then I'm gonna do some
Tony Robbins in New York after this and
it feels like it's a neverending cascade
of travel I could probably have a guess
but this this family time means a lot
and I'm excited that next to police so
if you guys want to catch my last travel
video of the vacation that took with
Nina to Venice in Greece there's a link
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there